la pandémie a exacerbé les problèmes
d'anxiété pour bien des jeunes au québec
inquiétude face au confinement isolement
social enseignement à la maison toutes
ces raisons ont motivé le gouvernement
du québec a dépêché deux cent soixante
intervenants psychosociaux dans les
écoles primaires et secondaires de la
province pour soutenir les élèves en
détresse psychologique
j'ai deux invités ce soit très
préoccupés par cette question là jasmin
roy fondateur de la fondation jasmin roy
% jasmin - bonsoir bienvenue à 24 soit
son eric pras nouveau président de la
fédération du personnel de soutien
scolaire bonsoir monsieur pronovost et
je commence avec vous parce que vous
avez sont des veaux trente mille membres
qui travaillent en milieu scolaire ça va
des technicienne en travail social je
pense à toutes les autres corps de
métier il avait trente mille personnes
30 mille travailleurs et vous avez
constaté semble-t-il cette augmentation
de la détresse psychologique qu'est ce
que c'est respectivement et fête ses
vingt deux sauts un sondage qui ne nous
surprend pas 85% de nos gens qui
travaillent sur le terrain n'avait dames
et stoller des techniciens en éducation
spécialisée les éducateurs et les égards
tous ces gens là constate clairement qu'
il ya une détresse et mais aussi au
niveau du secondaire cette détresse
touche de plus en plus et beaucoup plus
les jeunes qui sont aux seconds
elle s'exprime comme un écouter entre
autres dont on a ressorti de différents
éléments entre autres la réduction de
des relations directes vous savez le
fameux présentiel entraîne la crainte
d'un vote aussi au confinement
ça ajoute énormément l'anxiété chez nos
jeunes on a aussi tout la restriction au
niveau des groupes bulle parce que vous
comprendrez que ils sont beaucoup plus
enclavées sont beaucoup plus entre eux
donc ça vient aussi apporté une lourd
barre puis on a aussi les étudiants une
grande part sur justement leur
cheminement scolaire
ils ont une crainte par rapport à ça il
sole à ses managers etc
vraiment c'est vraiment un lien avec
l'apprentissage
il est tout la lourdeur de la part des
milles au ski et sur le dos de nos
enfants
j'imagine j'espère voir que ces
résultats ne vous étonne pas non ça
m'étonne pas je suis un peu étonné par
exemple de l'extrait que vous avez pas
si tu me dises roberge
je suis content aujourd'hui qui est de
la date de la vague qui met plus de
ressources en place mais nous depuis le
mois de mai avec le community québécois
des jeunes en difficulté de comportement
et on de 30 spécialistes se sont penchés
pour créer un coffre à outils pour
soutenir les jeunes dans l'horizon
émotionnels et relationnels en temps de
pandémie un an contexte de pandémie on
s'est assis avec des chercheurs pour
réfléchir là dessus on les a interpellés
puis et jamais personne qui nous est
revenu puis on leur envoie encore là le
message aujourd'hui que quand il ya
trente spécialistes comme ça et que la
fondation jasmin roy sophie des marais
avec le comité québécois des jeunes en
difficulté le comportement se mobilisent
et tous ces gens là ont travaillé de
façon bénévole
ça serait peut-être intéressant qui
s'assoit avec nous autres puis qu'on
puisse travailler de pair parce que ces
outils là vont servir le aux
travailleurs sociaux qui vont entrer
dans les écoles
puis il ya aussi tout un problème compte
que pas été réfléchi on est arrivé avec
des règles sanitaires dans les écoles
pour la rentrée du rattrapage académique
on est très content de ça mais on n'a
jamais réfléchi sur le bien-être des
gens l'école et pas juste le bien-être
des enfants le bien-être des adultes on
les laisse pas si respirer présentant
dans les écoles on sent déjà de
l'essoufflement chez les professionnels
il faut faire attention parce que quand
les adultes ne vont pas bien dans les
écoles les enfants ne vont pas bien donc
il faut avoir en plus des règles
sanitaires mettent en place des mesures
éducatives et des mesures pour s'assurer
du bien-être de tous
et ça veut peut-être dire aussi coupé
quelques jours d'école par semaine ou
d'ajouter des journées pédagogiques mais
sinon on passera pas à travers qu'on va
se retrouver dans le même cas avec le
réseau scolaire que les sièges celle des
arts passer quelques secondes jasmin
ouest sur votre coffre à outils
donnez-nous juste un exemple pendant que
vous parliez tout à l'heure on le
montrait là c'est un site ont pu aller
un clic on a des réponses à nos
questions
allez-y rapidement pour susciter
l'intérêt d'aller le constructeur
dans le fond un volet pour les parents
puis rapidement on peut cliquer petite
enfance on peut cliquer primaire ou
secondaire c'est la même chose pour les
intervenants et les enseignants et
ensuite on est des outils on peut
filtrer les outils selon les besoins si
on a des besoins pour gérer la colère
gérer l'anxiété aussi pour favoriser
comme on disait tout à l'heure de poser
déjà qu'avec vous parliez de faciliter
la socialisation même dans les mesures
de restriction c'est faisable et nous on
était c'est sûr qu'on ne peut pas
réinventer la roue mais j'ai demandé aux
experts d'aller un peu plus loin et
d'ailleurs le 24 novembre prochain on va
se pencher on va faire le bilan est
d'ailleurs encore invité tous les les
ministres l'éducation le ministre la
famille le ministre de la santé oms ne
pas de réponse à savoir s'ils vont être
là parce que j'ai six recherches qui
vont représenter pour faire le bilan de
la rentrée scolaire et c'est quoi les
besoins émotionnels et relationnels de
nos jeunes présents parce que je prenais
vous certes et puis je n'ai pas la
preuve le jeu pose la question à ceux ci
la deuxième vague la rentrée scolaire
les jeunes sont vecteurs ne respectes
pas en dehors des écoles et sa relance
le fameux port du masque à plusieurs
niveaux additionnels obligatoire pas
seulement dans les corridors mais aussi
assis en classe et tout ça est ce que
votre fédération a une fille nature une
position près des écoles et ultimement
parce que là j'ai annoncé tout à l'heure
la fermeture d'une autre école à 1 2 500
postes sont touchés
effectivement madame tussauds que le
port du masque
depuis le début nous ce qu'on dit c'est
que on veut des consignes claires des
mesures claires pour nos intervenants
qui viennent de la santé publique et qui
ne sont surtout pas à travers parce que
vous savez la santé publique par le
ministre le ministère pâle au sein de
services scolaires et à partir de l'aube
un e
il ya un espèce d'épuration où les
règles sont interprétées différemment
nous ce qu'on dit l'ordre doit venir du
côté de sanitaires pour nous
sûr d'une chose pour nous assurer des
écoles en sécurité eu du talent là
j'écoutais le suroît et bravo parce que
je trouve que ce guide l'on va retenir a
été beaucoup de gens entre autres à
aider les parents aussi les outiller ces
gens là et à partir du moment où quand
l'enfant arriveront entre les quatre
murs vont être importants lots d'engager
d'aller chercher des gens pour justement
travaillé avec les élèves l'eau qui ont
des difficultés présentes en dessous
vous le savez on est en pénurie de main
d'oeuvre
mais une chose est sûre la pénurie de
mes deux n'est pas arrivé à cause de
cette panne il aux élites lots à 20,5
rares et la maison notre besoin que nos
intervenants oui soro ou cinq par le
guide de de monsieur mais une chose est
sûre il va falloir qu'on mette des
actions très clair pour avoir autant dit
son collègue éducateur spécialisé
parce que ça ne fonctionne repos il faut
aider ces gens lomé pour aider les
étudiants et leurs parents kg leur
tournée jasmin roy pour le monde la fin
jasmin roy
un mot sur le port du masque pour éviter
la fermeture des écoles parce que les
écoles doivent rester ouvertes ne serait
ce que pour permettre aux enfants et aux
adolescents des temps faibles j'imagine
moi je les attends il faut essayer le
plus possible chose d'accord avec
monsieur legault là dessus de garder les
jeunes à l'école c'est important pour
leur développement le développement du
cerveau développement des apprentissages
mais il faut aussi s'assurer du
directoire journée à la maison et des
professeurs qui reprennent leur souffle
et et si le gouvernement n'y arrive pas
on est là pour le supporter il ya des
gens qui veulent se mobiliser qui sont
l'homme et je lance le message quand m
ce soir monsieur legault on est là on
veut vous aider là mais et répondez-nous
répondu non très bien jasmin roy merci
beaucoup continuer vos travail ne se
produire c'est fini mais on reste
informé avec si vous et vos membres qui
vous donne
la rétroaction sur ce qui se passe sur
les terres et merci à vous courage merci
merci